he had coach of the Dallas Cowboys and
that is coach Jason Garrett coach how
are you doing I'm doing great Michael
how are you coach I I'm doing great
coach I'm sitting in for the great Rich
Eisen I told him this is right up there
with the top of the things that I've
ever accomplished in life cause rich is
such a great do and I appreciate you
taking the time to give us a moment
coach yeah big shoes to fill
aizen's a legend my coach talked to me
about all that's going on now how do you
feel about the draft in the guys that
you got in the draft I know you got you
were smart enough to go and get to 5th
rounders out of do you talk to me about
all those guys you know we feel great
about the group you know we haven't had
a chance to see them yet but you know
you go through so much evaluation of
these players you know leading up to the
draft and our scouts have been on these
guys for over a year and then we as
coaches once the season is over we start
diving into it as well and you have so
many discussions and so many meetings
and you talk about what you want the
team to be all about and then you talk
about the kind of players you want in
each position to make the team be what
you want it to be the identity of the
team all of those things and so it's a
very thoughtful process that we go
through there's a lot of different
decisions that you make along the way
and and then you're on the clock and and
ultimately you know you pick certain
guys to add to your team and you know we
feel great about you know those three
days we weren't pre active in day one
but you know day two and day three we
feel like we got a lot of good players
and you know it'd be fun to get them in
here this weekend you know we do our
mini camp two weeks after the draft kind
of let the whole thing breathe a little
bit and then once we get our players in
here we get a chance to have them for
the rest of the offseason so we'll first
get a chance to be around them on
Thursday night we'll spend three days
with them this weekend and then
integrate them into the into the
offseason program you know we started
with Tristan Hill you know defensive
lineman from Central Florida who you
know we think has a lot of the traits
that we want in that three technique
that under tackle he's big but more than
that he's quick he's explosive he's
powerful and very disruptive and he's a
really young player and we feel like we
we
in a really good environment with with
Rod Marinelli and Leon Lett coaching
them every day and guys like DeMarcus
Lawrence and Tyrone Crawford showing
them the way to do it each and every day
we just feel like he can grow into
something that we really like and you
know Connor McGovern was someone we took
in the third round and really it was
just the quintessential blinking light
you know we looked up at her draft board
and he was graded by far the highest on
the board and we just said hell let's
take the best football player here so so
good about those guys you know in day
two and then got a number of players in
day three like I said a couple
University of Miami guys want to make
sure we continue that tradition so many
great players and this organization came
from Miami and there's something about
those Miami guys I'm not just telling
you this but there's a competitive
spirit to them their love of football so
we want to keep injecting that into our
team so excited about those guys and the
rest of the crew we got on day three you
listen to coach Jason Garrett of the
Dallas Cowboys here on the Rich Eisen
show on my core of is sitting in for
Rich Eisen coach when you talk about how
that Draft has gone and it kind of
reminds me of the days when we were
there when you would just seem like
everybody was we were drafting was
really for the backup positions we
drafted so well and you guys have
drafted so well that now it's about
supporting the guys that you have on the
football field and and that seems like
what it's doing what kind of
expectations will that bring to the
Dallas Cowboys this season when we
basically say we're using a draft just
to support the starters we already have
now well you know I respectfully
disagree with you a little bit about on
that and I think I think from the
outside that can be the perception but I
think as much as anything else what
we're trying to do with every decision
we make is to create competition on our
football team and you can say in May
that boy you have a starter here and a
starter there and boy you're the
offensive lines back and this guy is
going to play here and that guy's going
to play there you know one of the things
you know we've all discovered a long
time ago is you have to create
competition with every decision that you
make and you know at the outset
certainly the players we've had will
have a
a distinct advantage they've been
starters they've been playing a lot but
you want to create competition
throughout your team for guys to make
the team guys to have a role on the team
and certainly guys who were one of the
22 starters and each of these guys we
brought in we're just excited to see and
we're going to put them out there and
we're going to see how they compete with
the guys that we already have and and
hopefully at the end of it we'll pick
the best guy to to make our team the
best guy to have a role and ultimately
the best guy to start and have a big
impact and we feel like each of these
guys have the different levels of the
draft can come in and do that and so we
never want to get into a mode of okay
we're all set here not now we're just
drafting back up players you know this
league changes too much from year to
year you got to draft players who can
contribute can compete can challenge the
guys who are already there I think
hopefully were able to do that that's
coach Dixon Gary head coach for the
Dallas Cowboys coach and on the rich I
didn't show on my core was sitting in
for Rich Eisen coach you also brought in
some some great players and I was doing
the show with Marvin Lewis and one of
the things we talked about was and the
free agency show was a guy that you
picked up he said Marvin Lewis at that
time he thought the best free agent out
there and if he was out there hunting he
would go hunting for this kid was
Randall Cobb talk about how Randall Cobb
can help the Dallas Cowboys this season
well he just been such a good player for
so long and you know Colby's League you
know playing that slot receiver role for
us the last few years was very impactful
and and just a really really good
football player and anybody who's
followed our team knows that not only
make a lot of catches but he made a lot
of catches in important moments third
down down in the red zone always seem to
come up with with plays that made a
difference and you know he had an
opportunity to go up to Buffalo and it
was it was one of those things that it
was hard for us to match financially
what they were offering him so you know
we had to say okay B's is gone now what
do we do let's look at the landscape and
you know Randall Cobb has been so we've
been trying to cover for seven eight
years now he had such a big impact on
what they were doing up in Green Bay
they used him a lot of different ways
inside outside the handling the ball he
lined up in the backfield and
just that versatility we feel like it
can have a really positive impact on our
offense and you know from afar you feel
like you're no guys and he always struck
me as somebody who was just a real pro
and you know knew the game understood
the game you know play with great poise
just seemed like a real professional
football player and then we've had a
chance to get to know him through the
free agency process and then have him
here the last couple months he's exactly
that someone who just goes about the
right way every day and has such a
positive influence on some of the
younger receivers we've had already to
see guys had that kind of success how he
approaches it each day easy to see why
he's been so successful throughout his
career that is head coach of the Dallas
Cowboys coach Jason Garrett here on the
Rich Eisen show on Mike Corbitt sitting
in for rich richer I retire now and I'll
coach you said you know of talking about
the free agency and the guys who just
picked up and a great professional
there's another great profession when it
came back that you picked up a free
agent call Jason Wynn tell me how did
that process get started of Jason Witte
when coming back to the Dallas Cowboys
well you know if you've been around with
you said it he's the ultimate
professional and you know I don't know
that I've ever been around a guy who
loved it more who embraced every part of
the game as much as Jason Witten has and
just fortunate to be around him and
coach him for a number of years and he
comes into the building every day he
just can't get enough of it and he and I
had a lot of discussions prior to him
taking the Monday night job and you know
some really heartfelt discussions about
you know where he is and where he wants
to go and and this opportunity they had
in front of him and you know I think all
throughout that process I got the sense
that it was hard for him to just leave
he felt like there was still meat on the
bone in this career or what he wanted to
accomplish and and like I said he just
loved it and I think so many people
expressed to him that that's a rare
opportunity it's hard to get a chance to
go you know be the lead analyst on
Monday Night Football you need to take
that but I think all the while I think
his heart was
I'm here and so we went through that
process I think if you'd ask him you
know I think he'd say had a really good
experience and and over the course of
that last year I think he probably felt
like he was getting better and learning
it a little bit more but ultimately he
just listened to his heart about what he
wanted to do and he came back we had
some discussions you know after the
season and you know you only get a
chance to live once and you want to
embrace what you what you're passionate
about and there was no doubt in my mind
he was passionate about doing this so I
certainly encouraged him for him as
someone who was advising him but also
for our football team I know have a a
really positive impact on us just
because of how he goes about things and
he's been such a such a significant
player for this organization for a long
time so excited to have him back he
looks great he looks like the same guy
and it's so great to have him in the
building yeah and I think he will be a
great asset down so so you're saying you
called him oh he called you I would say
that he probably called me and you know
we had a chance to be around each other
a couple times after the end of the
season so you know it was just something
that came up and again I think it was on
his mind really since the day he
announced his retirement this idea that
boy I want to keep playing football and
again we're excited to have him back I'm
talking to a coach Jason Gary here under
Rich Eisen Sean Michael Irvin sitting in
for Rich Eisen and one more guy want to
ask you about that I've been thinking a
lot about and I'm sure a lot of people
out there at all right thinking about is
Travis Frederick how was he doing Travis
is doing great and you know again we've
been using this work professional a lot
I mean talk talk about the consummate
Pro he's been you know from day one with
us he's just got about things the right
way in a very professional manner and
you know just one of those guys that you
as a coach you're always pointing to and
say do it like number 72 does and you
know he was challenged by a very odd
situation last year and you know you
know typically you're dealing with
orthopedic injuries or soft tissue
injuries with players but to have this
the the the syndrome that he had to deal
with kind of come into his life I mean
that was not an easy situation
again I just thought he handled it so
beautifully you know he wasn't able to
play for us and he embraced a different
role he was one of the best leaders we
had on her team last year he was in
every meeting at every walkthrough just
just part of our football team through
and through and it helps so many people
out you know Jill Looney who wasn't
played for him some of the other guys in
the offensive line and and some of the
younger guys that were just playing on
our team we had a really young team and
his leadership you know made a big
difference and you know I think he I was
feeling better and better over the
course of the year better since the
offseason has started and and has really
been completely a part of our offseason
program he looks really good he looks
like the same guy we went out in the
field for the first time last week he's
taking part in all of that he's lifting
he's running and he looks like the old
Travis Frederick and again we're excited
to have him back as co-chair of the
Dallas Cowboys here on the Rich Eisen
show I'm Michael Irvin sitting in for
rich coach we had Jerry Jones on
yesterday and he talked and raised
reviews about that Prescott and and and
that how he's all-in on dak Prescott and
and it's so funny because I was with
Ezekiel Elliott the other day and got a
chance to talk to him about the fishing
trip that the doc in and he and all the
offensive linemen had just gone on and
and hung out together now we talked Jer
about what Dad does on the football
field but but how important is it that
Dax the kind of leader and he does the
things he does off the football field
like taking all of those guys on that
trip well how much of that plays into
the role when you go to Jerry and say
listen we got to have this guy you got
to do a contract no matter what how much
of all that plays into it well he's just
a fantastic leader and if you think
about his arc as a player with us you
know we draft him in the fourth round
and in 16 with the idea that Tony Romo
was gonna be our quarterback and we
needed to get a young guy in here to
hopefully compete for the backup spot
but also potentially be a guy who became
our next quarterback and and you all
know what happened obviously Tony got
hurt and dak was was pressed into being
our starting quarterback as a rookie
first year out of college and and he
came in and just played so well and the
markable thing
me about all of that was just watching
him handle the whole thing that's not an
easy situation to be in
Tony Mabus who was a great player for
organization for a number of years to
kind of step into his shoes a lot of
veteran players on that team when you're
a rookie quarterback you step in the
huddle you have all these guys who were
very accomplished how you handle that
you know we won a lot of games in a row
how do you handle that success we had
some adversity how to handle that and at
every turn he just handled things so
beautifully he sucked a mature guy he's
got a great perspective on life he loves
football he loves what he does he's got
this infectious contagious personality
where you know guys just are so willing
to follow him and and the reason is
because he kind of connects with them
and does everything everybody else is
doing and and just has a very very
unique way of being able to relate to
and connect with so many different guys
on our team but throughout our
organization so you know I think we saw
that right from the start
and that's only continue to grow here
the last couple of years he's had a lot
of success you know he started 48
regular season games he's won 32 of them
you know I think that ranks among the
best with guys their first year their
first three years out of school so he's
done a lot of really positive things on
the field been very impactful there but
like you said it's been equally
significant off the field and you know
he loves the guys on our team the
offensive guys the defensive guys just
he loves being around them the older
guys the younger guys guys from
different parts of the country he just
has a way of connecting with them and
developing a relationship and they all
respond really well to them and you know
they've been going on these fishing
trips the last couple years and they
have some great pictures and great
stories they come back with so I just
think it's a really positive thing for
our team and he's certainly the leader
of it that voice you hear that was
Cowboys head coach Jason Garrett here on
the Rich Eisen show on my Corvis sitting
in for Rich Eisen one of the other
things Jerry talked about was Kellen
Moore the young offensive coordinator he
kind of said in
and what he was seeing was that he has
confidence all the confidence in the
world and Kelly more but he also has
extra he has a backup confidence in
knowing that you're back there to back
him up in case things don't don't go as
well or or he need some guidance in a
tough spot what are your thoughts on
that well you know Kelly is one of those
guys that probably since he was in high
school he had a lot of success as a
starting quarterback and and so many
people would attribute that success to
his understanding of the game he's just
a really bright guy you know in life but
also when it comes to football and and
he goes on to Boise and wins a ton of
games there and then he's been playing a
number of years here in the NFL and
that's probably lying one when anyone
describes Kellen he's just he's a smart
football guy he gets it he he
understands the game and so you know
we've been around her for a few years
now and we understood you know that
about him as well and he was it was a
really strong contributor from his role
as a backup quarterback to some of the
things we were doing I think he had a
really positive impact on dak when he
was a player and when he decided that he
wanted to get into coach and we just
felt like it was a good move for him to
be our quarterback coach and you know we
understand that we've accelerated him
you know really really quickly his
second year of coaching to be the
offensive coordinator we get that I had
a little bit of confidence in it because
I took a little bit of a similar route I
was a quarterback coach for two years
before becoming an offensive coordinator
and has been in his shoes and I think
the biggest thing I learned there was
you want to put your stamp on it you
want to put your mark on it you want to
you know there's so many things that you
have inside of you that you want the
offense to be but but learning how to
use the the people around you was
probably the biggest takeaway from the
experience that I had a lot of veteran
coaches on the staff when I came here to
Dallas in oh seven and you know Tony
Sparano was here a great football coach
Wade Wilson was here you know a number
of other guys skip Pete my brother John
was the tight ends coach ray Sherman was
the receiver coach a lot of guys who
have been around football for a long
time and it was a very collaborative
effort that we had
and I think that's the one thing that I
shared with Kellan is we want to put
your stamp on this thing but understand
the other guys you have in that room
have been around for a number of years
Sanjay allowed Doug nussmeier Gary Brown
you know mark Columbo is a young coach
himself but he's been around our system
and what we do and and some other other
experiences as well so a lot of veteran
guys around him and I think Ellen's done
a great job putting his stamp on it but
also using the resources that he's had
and he's really off to a good start it's
fun to get with our players it's fun to
see him in action and you know what
we're excited about our offense is going
as head coach Justin Guerin of the
Dallas Cowboys here on the Rich Eisen
show I am Michael Irvin sitting in for
Rich Eisen coach you got 10 years as the
head coach of the Dallas Cowboys now I
want to ask you a couple things here
would you say that this is your best
team and your best opportunity to get to
a Super Bowl since you've been here
coach of the Dallas Cowboys and does
that put any pressure on you to do to
actually accomplish that and get this
team to a Super Bowl you know Michael
I've never really looked at it that way
that this team is better than that team
or whatever certainly when I first
became the coach if you look at the
cycle of our of our team you know we had
to move on from a number of players who
had been here for a while really good
players and they had gotten a little bit
older they were making some money so we
had to make some hard decisions we
completely revamped our offensive line
in year one we had a lot of new guys
play and young guys play and I think I
think as we got into this thing a little
bit the biggest thing we're trying to do
was was build this team the right way
and if you think about you know our
first draft pick was Tyron Smith we also
drafted DeMarco Murray in that first
draft so so guys who really represent
what we want our team to be all about so
we've continued to try to do that over
the last seven eight years and we've
been able to build our offensive line
we've been continuing try to build our
defensive line and really all throughout
our team with the expression I use is
the right kind of guys guys who are
driven guys who love to play ball guys
who want to be part of a team willing to
sack
all those things that that we think are
so important those are the kinds of guys
who make up championship teams and and
so we've just continued to try to do
that and make really good decisions and
build the team the right way and
hopefully build a team we're all proud
to be a part of and you know we talk
about it if your goals aren't to win the
Super Bowl you're in the wrong business
you should be doing something else
so that's something we absolutely talk
about on day one but we also talk about
you know building a championship
mentality and going about the right way
each and every day to be our best so we
can be the best and those are the
expressions we use that that's the
approach that we take so we're very much
focused on what we need to do today
Tuesday May 7th to be our best as
coaches and as players and we'll
continue to focus on that we have high
expectations for ourselves in terms of
our approach and what we want to
accomplish and that's really where our
focus always stays of course I want to
wish you best of luck this season thanks
for taking the time to call in on the
Rich Eisen show and give me a moment to
talk chat coats absolutely Michael
you're the best all right good luck
ok take care for more of the Rich Eisen
show tune - audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV for free on VR live or download
the Rich Eisen show app